.
DON'T FORGET TO DOWN LOAD THE
PODCAST EVERY MORNING.
JUST GO TO CNN.COM.
>>> MITCH McCONNELL SHOOTING
DOWN SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM'S
BILL THAT WOULD BAN ABORTIONS
NATIONWIDE AFTER 15 WEEKS OF
PREGNANCY.
>> IN TERMS OF SCHEDULING, I
THINK MOST OF THE MEMBERS OF MY
CONFERENCE PREFER THAT THIS BE
DEALT WITH AT THE STATE LEVEL.
>> SO AS McCONNELL SAID THERE,
THIS BILL RUNS COUNTER TO THE
STATEMENTS MADE BY MANY
REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE SAID
PUBLICALLY THAT THE ISSUE OF
ABORTION SHOULD BE LEFT UP TO
THE STATES, INCLUDING GRAHAM
HIMSELF.
THIS IS WHAT THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SENATOR SAID IN
AUGUST AND WHAT HE SAID
YESTERDAY.
>> I'VE BEEN CONSISTENT.
I THINK STATES SHOULD DECIDE THE
ISSUE OF MARRIAGE AND STATES
SHOULD DECIDE THE ISSUE OF
ABORTION.
I HAVE RESPECT FOR SOUTH
CAROLINA.
SOUTH CAROLINA VOTERS HERE, I
TRUST TO DEFINE MARRIAGE AND TO
DEAL WITH ISSUE OF ABORTION.
I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A LAW AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT WOULD
SAY, AFTER 15 WEEKS, NO ABORTION
ON DEMAND, EXCEPT IN CASES OF
RAPE, INCEST, TO SAVE THE LIFE
OF THE MOTHER AND THAT SHOULD BE
WHERE AMERICA IS AT.
>> JOINING ME NOW, CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR MARGARET HOOVER,
JOHN AVALON AND ALYSSA GRIFFIN.
BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL POLITICAL IMPACT OF
WHAT LINDSEY GRAHAM IS DOING
HERE.
I WANT SOMEONE TO TAKE A STAB AT
WHAT'S DRIVING HIM TO DO THAT.
MARGARET YOU VOLUNTEERED?
>> I SIGNED UP.
THE RULE IN ALMOST ALL THINGS IN
LIFE WHEN YOU'RE IN A HOLE, STOP
DIGGING.
REPUBLICANS ARE IN A HOLE ON THE
ISSUE OF CHOICE, ON DOBBS, THE
OVERTURNING OF ROE V. WADE.
THIS IS NOT GOING WELL.
WHAT WE CAN SEE FROM ALL THE
POLLING AND VOTER REGISTRATION,
ESPECIALLY WITH WOMEN IN KEY
STATES IN THE ELECTION IS THAT
THE GAINS THAT DEMOCRATS HAVE
MADE HAS BLUNTED, SEVERELY
BLUNTED POTENTIALLY THE
ADVANTAGE REPUBLICANS HAD
HISTORICALLY GOING INTO THIS
ELECTION.
SO WHAT MITCH McCONNELL NEEDS
LINDSEY GRAHAM TO STOP DOING IS
TALKING ABOUT ABORTION.
AND WHAT LINDSEY GRAHAM IS
TRYING TO DO IS TALKING ABOUT
THE VERY SPECIFIC SLICE OF THE
ISSUE THAT REPUBLICANS WIN ON,
WHICH IS WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
LATE TERM ABORTION AND
REPUBLICANS ARE LOSING BECAUSE
THE ENTIRE DEBATE IS NOW ABOUT
THE FACT THAT WOMEN HAVE LOST A
RIGHT THAT THEY HAD FOR 50 YEARS
BECAUSE OF A CONSERVATIVE COURT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
SORRY, GO AHEAD.
>> THE TIMING ALSO AS A
REPUBLICAN WAS FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE YESTERDAY THE TERRIBLE
INFLATION NUMBERS COME OUT.
THAT'S WHAT THE REPUBLICANS NEED
TO RUN ON, AHEAD OF THE
MIDTERMS.
THE ECONOMY IS STRUGGLING, THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT HASN'T
DONE ENOUGH TO DRIVE DOWN COSTS
BUT INSTEAD LINDSEY GRAHAM
CONSUMES THE NEWS CYCLE BY GOING
ROGUE AGAINST REPUBLICAN
ORTHODOX, WHICH THIS IS SHOULD
BE DETERMINED BY STATES.
MITCH McCONNELL IS SMART TO NOT
BRING IT UP, THAT WILL
CRIPPLE --
>> IT'S NOT A REAL BILL.
IF YOU WANT TO PASS A BILL YOU
GET MITCH McCONNELL ON YOUR SIDE
FIRST, YOU DON'T SURPRISE HIM
WITH A PRESS CONFERENCE WITH THE
ACTIVIST GROUPS AND SPECIAL
INTEREST ON THE FAR RIGHT.
>> THE QUESTION IS WHY LINDSEY
GRAHAM IS WALKING ACROSS THE
STREET TO PUNCH HIMSELF IN THE
FACE.
>> POOR LINDSEY.
>> THAT'S WHAT HE'S DOING TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY RIGHT HERE.
HANGING A LANTERN ON THE FACT
THERE'S HYPOCRISY ON THE ISSUE
OF STATE'S RIGHTS, THIS IS O
OPPOSITE.
REPUBLICANS SAYING FOR A LONG
TIME IT SHOULDN'T BE DECIDED BY
THE COURTS, IT SHOULD BE
DESPITED BY THE STATES.
WE SAW LINDSEY GRAHAM SAY THAT
IN AUGUST AND NOW REVERSING IT.
IF THERE IS AN ATTEMPT TO EXCITE
THE BASE I THINK THEY'RE FIRED
UP BUT IT HANGS A LANTERN ON
THEIR PROBLEM AND IT DOESN'T
HELP IN THIS CASE.
>> YOU WERE GOING TO SAY?
>> CONSERVATIVES ARE FOR THE
STATES DETERMINING IT, UNLESS,
OF COURSE, CONGRESS WERE TO PASS
A FEDERAL BILL.
WHAT THEY WERE NEVER FOR IS FOR
THE COURT DETERMINING IT.
>> IT'S THE SAME THING.
IT UNDERCUTS THE ARGUMENT.
>> MY FIRST QUESTION IS WHY
LINDSEY GRAHAM IS DOING THIS.
I'M NOT SATISFIED THERE'S A
CLEAR ANSWER.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> LOOK, WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THIS
ISSUE, WHICH IS A VERY DIFFICULT
ISSUE, IS THAT ACTUALLY THE
COUNTRY IS MOSTLY UNITED.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T WANT LATE TERM
ABORTIONS.
MOST PEOPLE WANT RESTRICTIONS
AROUND IF -- RESTRICTIONS BUT
PROTECTIONS, FRANKLY, AROUND THE
ABILITY FOR WOMEN TO HAVE AN
ABORTION IN FIRST TRIMESTER AND
EARLY TERM.
WE ARE ALSO MOSTLY AGREED ABOUT
THAT BUT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
STAKED OUT AN EXTREME POSITION
AND THEY'RE LOSING ON IT.
IF THEY TALK ABOUT THE PART
EVERYBODY AGREES WITH, PERHAPS
LINDSEY THINKS THIS WILL CHANGE
IF ISSUE AND THE CONVERSATION
AROUND REPUBLICANS LOSING ON THE
ISSUE.
>> MY BEST INTERPRETATION IS
HE'S PULLING BACK A RELIC WHEN
ROE WAS THE LAW OF THE LAND.
MY PARTY VOTED ON A BILL THAT
WOULD BAN ABORTION AT 20 WEEKS.
MOST PEOPLE BELIEVE IN ACCESS
BUT SOME RESTRICTIONS ON
ABORTION.
AFTER THE DOBBS DECISION, THE
REPUBLICANS WERE SAYING THIS
SHOULD BE DETERMINED BY THE
STATES.
SO FOR REPUBLICANS TO COME IN
WITH THIS LAW IS NEGATING THE
ARGUMENT WE WERE MAKING.
>> REPUBLICANS WERE SAYING NO
THERE WON'T BE A NATIONAL
ABORTION BAN AND WHAT'S LINDSEY
GRAHAM SAYING?
>> THERE'S GOING
>> AS WITH MOST THINGS, THERE IS
A CENTRIST SOLUTION THAT COULD
UNITE THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, BUT THE
EXTREMES KEEP HIJACKING THE
ARGUMENT.
>> BY THE WAY, WHERE'S LINDSEY
GRAHAM ON ABORTION -- EXCUSE ME,
NOT ABORTION, BUT CODIFYING
MARRIAGE EQUALITY.
MANY REPUBLICANS WHO DON'T WANT
TO HAVE FEDERALLY SAID IT'S A
STATE'S ISSUES.
THAT COULD COME INTO CONFLICT.
>> IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT RIGHT
NOW, PLANNING ON WHAT TO DO WITH
THIS, WHAT'S YOUR NEXT STEP?
>> KEEP LET THEM TALKING ABOUT
IT.
KEEP LET THEM GOING.
KEEP GIVING THEM ALL THE ROPE
THEY NEED TO HANG THEMSELVES.
>> HE GAVE YOU A GIFT.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, IT WAS A GIFT
TO DEMOCRATS.
I THINK THAT THE REPUBLICANS
NEED TO JUST BE FOCUSING ON THE
ECONOMY AND IT TOOK THE WIND OUT
OF THE SAILS OF WHAT WAS FRANKLY
NOT A GREAT EVENT FOR BIDEN AT
THE WHITE HOUSE YESTERDAY.
IT WAS THIS WEIRD, LIKE, WHY DID
WE HAVE JAMES TAYLOR THERE TO
LIKE CELEBRATE THE ECONOMY'S NOT
DOING VERY WELL, CONTINUING TO
GO FORWARD WITH THE EVENT AFTER
HAVING THESE BAD INFLATION
NUMBERS.
THAT'S WHERE THE PARTY SHOULD
BE.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE'RE RUNNING ON
ELECTION DENIALISM AND, YOU
KNOW, RESTRICTING ACCESS TO
ABORTION.
>> THERE'S NEVER A BAD TIME TO
HEAR FIRE AND REIGN, BUT THAT --
OBVIOUSLY, REPUBLICANS WANT TO
BE TALKING ABOUT INFLATION AND
CRIME, SO LINDSEY GRAHAM DOES
THEM NO HELP, BUT ALSO
REPUBLICAN PRIMARY VOTERS AREN'T
HELPING THEIR CASE EITHER.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
WE SHOULD NOTE, THEY ARE STILL
COUNTING VOTES IN NEW HAMPSHIRE,
BUT THAT ONE CANDIDATE IN THE
REPUBLICAN SENATE PRIMARY HAS
CONCEDED, CHUCK MORRIS WHO WAS
BACKED BY THE ESTABLISHMENT,
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR CHRIS
SUNUNU, BACKED BY ESTABLISHMENT
REPUBLICAN MONEY, A LOT OF IT,
CONCEDED, TO DON BOLLICK, A
RETIRED BRIGADIER GENERAL, WHO
IS SEEN AS VERY TRUMPY, FOR LACK
OF A BETTER WORD THERE.
SO WHAT DOES THIS TELL US,
ALYSSA?
>> IT JUST SHOWS THE
OVERWHELMING MAGA CONTROL OVER
THE PARTY.
CHRIS SUNUNU WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
BEST RECRUIT TO BEAT MAGGIE
HASSAN.
WHY WOULD A VERY POPULAR
GOVERNOR WHO COULD STAY IN HIS
SEAT FOREVER WANT TO STAY IN THE
SENATE IN THIS ENVIRONMENT.
NOW WE'VE GOT SOMEBODY WHO
ALMOST GUARANTEES AN UPHILL
BATTLE FOR REPUBLICANS TO FLIP
THAT SEAT.
ALSO, NEW HAMPSHIRE ONE, CAROLYN
LEAVITT WHO WORKED FOR ME.
I WAS A MATT MOWERS BACKER IN
THIS.
HE'S SOMEONE WHO COULD HAVE BEEN
A STRONGER GENERAL ELECTION
CANDIDATE AGAINST CHRIS PAPAS.
THIS FURTHER RIGHT CAROLINE.
>> I THINK IT DOES FOLKS ALMOST
A DISSERVICE TO SAY THEY'RE
TRUMPY.
I MEAN, LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT
THAT MEANS.
THAT MEANS ELECTION DENIAL IS A
LITMUS TEST.
THAT MEANS TE OF THE NEW
CANDIDATE WHO WORKED FOR YOU
THAT THINKS THAT JOE BIDEN
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED IS TRUE
REFLEXIVELY.
IN THE CASE OF THIS RETIRED
GENERAL, CALLING THE INCREDIBLY
POPULAR CHRIS SUNUNU, THE
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE, A
COMMUNIST SYMPATHIZER.
WE'RE TALKING, WE'RE TALKING
DETACHED FROM REALITY AS WELL AS
THE VAST MAJORITY OF VOTERS IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE, WHERE PLURALITY
VOTERS ARE REGISTERED
INDEPENDENTS.
>> AND THERE WAS GOOD TURNOUT
THERE.
A LOT OF INDEPENDENTS MAY HAVE
VERY WELL SHOWN UP TO VOTE.
I DO WANT TO POSE ONE QUESTION
HERE.
ONE THING, THE MEDIA, I THINK,
HAS CRITICIZED A GREAT DEAL WHAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE IN A LOT OF
THESE RACES, WHICH IS PUT MONEY
IN THERE TO TRY TO BOOST THE
ELECTION DENIER CANDIDATES,
RIGHT?
AND IF WE COULD PUT BACK ON THE
SCREEN, THE MARGINS RIGHT NOW IN
THAT SENATE RACE, YOU CAN SEE
THAT DON BOLDUC IS ONLY WINNING
BY A LITTLE BIT.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GETTING WHAT
THEY WANT.
THEY MAY BE CRITICIZED -- I'M
NOT PUTTING A VALUE JUDGMENT ON
IT.
THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
WHETHER IT'S THE RIGHT OR WRONG
THING TO DO.
THE ONLY THING IS, THEY'RE
GETTING WHAT THEY WANT UP AND
DOWN THE BOARD.
>> THEY'LL -- WELL, THAT
STORY -- THAT CHAPTER IS NOT
FINISHED, BECAUSE OF THE END OF
THE BOOK IS IN NOVEMBER.
THEY HAVE TO WIN AGAINST THOSE
ELECTION DENYING PRIMARY
CANDIDATES.
THEN, THAT'S THE END OF THE
STORY.
IF THIS ISN'T AN ADVERTISEMENT
FOR MODERATE REPUBLICANS TO
REALLY REFLECT ON HOW TO REFORM
THE PRIMARY SYSTEM SO THAT THEY
CAN GET COMPETITIVE CANDIDATES
THAT CAN WIN NATIONALLY, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IS.
I WILL SAY I'VE BEEN SAYING THIS
FOR SIX YEARS.
IT'S WEIRDLY BRINGING ME CLOSER
TO JOHN AVLON'S CENTRIST
POSITION, BUT TRULY, I MEAN,
THERE IS A REAL OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK.
LOOK AT RANK CHOICE VOTING.
WE'VE GOT TO KEEP OUR EYE ON
THAT IN ALASKA AS THAT'S COMING
UP.
MAYBE THAT KEEPS SOMEONE LIKE
SARAH PALIN FROM TAKING THAT
SEAT BACK.
AND THEN THERE WILL BE